if money really did grow on trees what
would everyone's favorite season be for
money what is money money is a mere
belief which is valued and used as a
medium of exchange for goods and
services money can be in any of these
forms namely coins printed papers
digital format but then why do we say
money is just a belief okay let's
imagine the scenario if we are given a
random piece of paper and are asked to
buy something out of it is it possible
clearly not this paper will hold value
only if you can buy goods and services
from it a random piece of paper which is
cut in the dimensions of a currency and
it's of the same color will not be able
to buy you any kinds of goods or
services but with the help of this paper
or to be precise with this currency
which is universally accepted as a
medium of transaction we can do that
right that's correct so we can say that
money in general is a belief okay let me
ask you a question here what do you
think is money in the economy fairly
distributed no it's not and why can't we
say so because we know that some
countries are rich while some are poor
so the obvious question anyone would ask
is that why can't the countries having
less money print more money and become
rich no they cannot and why is that so
let's understand that
[Music]
one-word answer to why a country cannot
randomly print any amount currency is
inflation hold on what is inflation
let's understand this term with the help
of an example here are the prices of one
kilogram of onions over a period of time
and what to be observe here we observe
that the prices are increasing over the
years that is for one kilogram of onions
a person had to pay 20 rupees in the
year 2014 but for the same 1 kilogram
the person paid 80 rupees in the year
2018 the important thing that we need to
note here is the value of money notice
that it has decreased over a period of
time confused
don't be let me elaborate in the year
2014 if you had 20 rupees you could
easily buy 1 kilogram of onions ok but
what about in the year 2018 that's
correct
you can buy only 250 grams of audience
for 20 rupees and that means if we
calculate the value of the same 20
rupees in terms of percentage then it's
reduced by 75% with respect to onions in
2014 so can we say that the buying power
of the consumer is reduced yes it has
this is nothing but inflation where the
prices of the goods or services
increases over a period of time
when inflation is calculated in terms of
percentage it's called the rate of
inflation now you may be thinking how is
inflation related to printing of money
hang on to understand this we need to
know an important concept called the GDP
that helps in deciding how much money
should be printed and what does GDP
it's the gross domestic product of a
country it's the total monetary value of
all final goods and services produced
within a country during a period of time
generally one year let me explain this
if we add up the value of goods like
food grains vehicles clothes etc and
services like consultancy internet
entertainment etc what we get is nothing
but GDP simple right knowing this a
country generally prints money which
accounts to a small percentage of the
GDP now you may ask why only a small
percent let's understand this with an
example now imagine a seller has ten
apples and to buy these apples the buyer
has an old ten dollars this means the
price of one Apple would be one dollar
now what if the buyer has ten more
dollars to buy the same ten apples the
price of each apple would be now two
dollars as the buying power has
increased but the quantity of apples has
remained the same the seller can demand
more money as he knows that the buyer
would be able to pay more did you get
any hint the value of money decreased
here that's because for the same $1 the
buyer cannot buy an apple now does to
maintain parity it's imperative that the
total amount of money should be in
proportion to the goods available
similarly what if the country randomly
prints money and floats it in the market
as compared to its GDP yes exactly
the prices of the commodities or
services would shoot up and do we know
what happens when the prices of the
commodities or services shooter that's
correct it results in inflation and when
the prices skyrocket it leads to
hyperinflation hyperinflation is a
situation where the rate of inflation is
more than 50 percent in a month over a
period of time for instance take the
price of a loaf of bread over months in
case of hyperinflation scary isn't it in
short printing more money would lead to
an increase in the prices bringing the
situation back to square one thus it
would do more harm than good right now
let me ask you a question here are the
nations dealing with hyperinflation yes
there are a few nations one of them is
Zimbabwe the country went on printing
money ignoring productivity unemployment
and poverty you would be stunned to know
that the rate of inflation in Zimbabwe
was seventy nine point six billion
percent month on month in the year 2008
which meets a loaf of bread could cost
you different denominations of
Zimbabwean dollar each time you went out
to buy one so what did the country do to
cope with the hyperinflation it went on
printing more money in different
denominations of Zimbabwean dollar even
when the country's productivity wasn't
doing that great
this led to too much money chasing fewer
Goods resulting in hyperinflation the
sad part is that the country is yet to
come out of hyperinflation now why don't
you search from other nations which are
suffering from hyperinflation and share
your findings in the comment section
below so coming back to printing of
money to avoid all such circumstances
the government considers a small percent
of GDP and also checks rate of inflation
before printing money okay
now you may ask why doesn't any country
just go on printing currencies and
import all the necessary goods is that
even possible well it's not and that's
because when imports of a country are
greater than the exports then the value
of its currency would start declining
and this again will lead to inflation
soak in any country print excessive
money definitely not now moving on let's
look at what we had told you about money
in the beginning we had told you that
money is a mere belief and it's widely
accepted in terms of coins printed
papers and in digital forms we know that
the currency was introduced due to the
lack of practicality of the barter
system do you think currency in these
forms would also be outdated some day in
the future what will be the future of
money is it going to be the same that
we're using now we hope you've heard
about cryptocurrencies well
cryptocurrencies be good transition from
money that we're using today what do you
think let us know your interesting
answers in the comment section below and
also do share this video with your
friends if you find it helpful happy
learning
[Music]